l'institut ou mensah a lancé un appel
aux dons en ligne basé à saint germain
en laye depuis 2014 la structure vient
en aide au quotidien aux victimes femmes
ou enfants de violences conjugales et
intrafamiliales
avec le retour du confinement la période
est critique pour le moment 2007 180
euros ont été collectés
aujourd'hui les moyens qui nous sont
alloués ne sont pas suffisants avec le
travail qui a aujourd'hui nous est
extrêmement écrasant en termes de moyens
nous ne voulons pas réduire le nombre de
consultations même si on les absorbent
mais on est quand même dans une
augmentation du nombre de consultations
très importante
là il faudrait effectivement qu'on
puisse être aidé pour pouvoir perd à
faire perdurer les consultations et puis
toute l'organisation qui s'est mis
autour car il a fallu que les équipes de
wim feys s'adapte à la crise sanitaire
pendant le premier confinement
l'institut a continué son action
virtuellement une continuité nécessaire
car la hausse des violences a été
considérable alors l'augmentation était
nette puisque de ça représente 250 %
d'augmentation à la même période donc
c'était c'était plus de 300 femmes que
nous avons reçus dans cette période là
quand on dit recevoir 300 femmes ça veut
dire qu'elles vont venir au moins dix
fois entre le psychologue les gants les
consultations psychologues juristes etc
en plus de l'appel aux dons l'institut
va également lancer une campagne de
communication avec des affiches dans les
commissariats et les lieux publics
le 25 novembre journée internationale de
lutte contre les violences bras
flashcode est la victime pourra
effectivement flashée ce qr code pour
déjà savoir qui nous sommes donc ça va
l'orienter vers notre site
elle pourra après se saisir de notre
notre numéro de téléphone pour nous
appeler nous expliquer la situation est
évidemment on va la prendre très
rapidement en charge selon le degré
d'urgence qu'elle nous aura
évoquer avec ce deuxième confinement
l'institut human life continue donc à
maintenir le lien avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée
les rendez vous peuvent avoir lieu par
téléphone ou au sein même des locaux